An invariant is a statement of a property that's always true.
You can think of it as an expression of a key system requirement.
Might be an essential relationship among the values of objects in,
in your system. The keyword that's used to indicate that, you know,
you're expressing an invariant constraint is inv. For example,
you might say in large companies that the official definition of
a large company is a company that has more than 50 employees.
And you could express a constraint that says that in OCL by having in
the context of the large company class. An invariant that
says its number of employee's attribute must be greater than 50.